um welcome anybody who's new and
everybody who's been here before welcome
back
as always we would like to acknowledge
some of our sponsors for this pie data
and our event
there's num focus who sponsors the
meetup itself TD Ameritrade whose offers
up this nice venue in space for us to be
using as well as Midas who chips in for
the food here a couple of important
points of people that are new emergency
exits in case of any emergencies as an
exit right here as well as one right
through that door that you came through
on the right and also we are looking for
speakers in the in the future we are
kind of backed up until with a line of
up until November now which is great but
also pre please provide any feedback
ongoing things that we're doing well
things that we're doing poorly but we'd
love to hear them
and also check out our github page we
tend to post our slides as well as any
other information on there and of course
unless you have a quick question please
try to hold it until the end and also
know that you are in a board space so
please try to clean up after yourselves
especially when we're getting food later
on so cops garbage I like to read the PI
D and a code of conduct for us so
partita is dedicated to providing a
harassment free meeting experience for
everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race or religion we
do not tolerate harassment of meeting
participants in any form all
communications should be appropriate for
professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our meet up events be kind to
others do not insult or put-down other
attendees behave professionally remember
that harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for pi data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meet up
at the sole discretion of the meetup
organizers but overall thank you for
making this a welcoming place for
everybody to enjoy but if you do any
issues definitely webinar you know we
have to facilitate our icebreaker so
we've always want people to be able to
meet somebody
beyond the company that they work for so
hopefully turn to somebody either maybe
in front of you behind you to your left
or right and introduce yourselves and
tell them the most interesting place
that you visited and go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so hopefully everybody here
today will have left
having met somebody new and that in the
data science space as well I would like
to chat about this month and data
science I know many are very hurt but at
Facebook Fair their artificial
intelligence research group they just
announced I guess are are opened up what
they're showing us sort of the developer
tools so whether it's frameworks and
tools for deep learning as well as
libraries and models but also tutorials
and giving the community access to them
and so go check them out it's really a
great resource to have additionally TD
Ameritrade we are hiring so it's Logan
here Levine ahlstrom on the advanced
analytics team they're hiring for both
data scientists and data analysts both
junior and senior positions so make sure
to check out on our careers page so our
jobs TD merger calm I was notified by
Denby bowl here but if you mention that
there's a new julia meetup group so go
check that out meetup space as well cool
I think it's like south southeast
Michigan Julia language group as well I
wanted to plug next month meetup so we
have lumic mckenna so I met Leland a
couple of years ago at PyCon and if
anybody's ever heard of you know all
these different clustering tools while
Leland did not publish the original HDTV
scan paper Leland was the one who
implemented HDTV skin so he's coming out
of Ottawa Canada but he's actually gonna
come up here to talk about one of his
new pieces of work called you map which
is some dimension a dimension ality
reduction tool that sort of competes
with T's knee and the PCA space so
definitely come and check that out
Leland really gives a great and fair
talk you ever seen some of the
documentation about HDB scan the
benchmarks are always in my opinion to
be very fair and honest so with that I'd
like to introduce our speaker for today
we have Travis Olaf I hear people who
are you know used to using things like
numpy sci-fi you have Travis to think so
he was the creator of numpy and I guess
founding contributed to sci-fi and I
learned today that Sipe I actually came
before numpy I thought it was the other
way around but Travis started that work
when he was at BYU as an assistant
professor and prior to that he was at
the Mayo Clinic doing his PhD after that
work he moved on and founded anaconda
right and then if you've used anything
like bouquet - numba right you name it
now I guess supporting pipe is as well
and data shader and so a lot of these
data science tools that we all sort of
see and hear about in our day-to-day we
really have Travis to thank for it as
well as anaconda crew that's right right
but he's here to talk to us about his
new venture he's recently moved on to a
new opportunity called aqua night and
they'll tell us hopefully a little bit
about that what about something yeah
presentation prepares I can't find so
talk about who knows what and then we'll
talk about I guess I'll be just
interacting live and maybe answering
questions and showing some things and
kind of trying to give a give a mental
model that's why I'm gonna borrow from a
few presentations I've given a lot of
talks with a little the best little
while so it's actually maybe that's why
I can't find anything somebody really
needs to build some kind of index for
presentations is so hard to find
material you've already done before it's
it's it's a problem so yeah I appreciate
the introduction it's a real pleasure to
be here I one of the things I really
love doing is going around anywhere
where there's a group people gathering
to try to figure out data science
particularly with Python but I also
liked my are friends and Oh Julia
friends as well and just trying to make
sense
this and it's a lot of fun because
things are going so fast and so furious
there's so much happening and I'd like
to start by giving a little bit of
context because I know there's so many
more people that have gathered to these
communities in then used to be here
right there used to be a lot of a lot of
shared knowledge and some of that shared
knowledge has drifted like it surprises
me that people think numpy came but like
after if I could before sci-fi right and
I guess it makes sense logically but the
wait number I came about because it was
a merger of the American memory a
numeric existed and I don't know sci-fi
on top of the America started that
project base is a grad student so I
instead of doing my PhD like I should
have done I was up writing software and
that actually played out multiple times
fernando has the same story John Hunter
had the same story several people have
that story so we have you know
procrastinating phd's the thing for a
lot of work but I really enjoyed doing
that I have a little bit here I think
what I'll do is maybe start with a
little bit of that story if I can go to
just have a tiny little bit of it and
this is right so I was in the Mayo
Clinic studying you know Star Trek
medicine that's what this is a professor
that inspired me there he wanted to
figure out how to make you know medicine
like start Star Trek and we were doing
AI back then or trying to I was doing
basically a Parzen window density
estimator to try to figure out how to
register two images together there's a
lot of really cool stuff we were working
on our way back then now with computing
was we had to deploy onto 15 different
unix versions h pucks and different from
sun and from all the all these other aux
there's a lot of platforms we had to
deploy to i was really doing science you
know I still consider myself first and
foremost to be a scientist to be
somebody who an engineer and scientist
who I love applied math I love to figure
out how does data lead to something when
I have a model so very curious about
those things I love neuroscience
celebrity and the latest advances that
led to Python it was that quest to try
to make science
better that led to how do I do this I
was kind of writing on my code and Pike
in MATLAB they didn't like the fact that
when I shared my coat with somebody they
had to have a license for this other
software I thought surely the world
could be better than essentially giving
somebody code they can't use unless
until they buy something I'm not against
buying things and so I didn't seem right
it said for like literacy was important
anyway now here's a library before you
can open this book you got to go pay
somebody to read this like that felt
really wrong even though I find selling
books that's great but so I came to
Python a long time ago right January and
basically 1996 or sorry 97 but it was
1.4 I would remember Python 1.4 raise
your hand yes sorry I'm gonna Python one
version a few years ago we started
anaconda we had a labor of pools joke
actually anaconda was known rcv Python
was known for its April Fool's jokes
it's kind of it's kind of funny it was
known for a long time so we put out one
a few years ago that was conned install
Python 1.0 and you can't you can still
do it actually because you can play with
come to Python 1.0 I did I was 1.4 it
was a lot of fun I saw was excited about
1.5 - and I remember the way I felt like
oh man Python 1.5 - it's so much better
and it was and then Python 2 had huge
strides huge strides and you know this
is back from PyCon which who's going to
Python by the way you know big on the
pike on either one arrived to Pike on
and I'm driving there tomorrow so if you
want a ride let me know we can have a
great talk on the way down to Cleveland
but it was back when there was about 20
of us right maybe 30 we just kind of
gathered around is also a workshop but
now of course there's there's 3030 hunt
there's a lot more people and it's
bigger much much bigger but it's still
get a chance to talk with with people
they're just regular people just people
interested in solving hard problems so I
start with sci-fi and it really was kind
of procrastinating my work kind of
because I thought well I really want to
use Python but it needs tools I need
special functions I need to be able to
write Bessel functions and be able to
calculate them I need integration order
ordinary differential equation
integration I was silly at MRIs and I
needed to be able to solve it OTE so I
don't do that well there was a Fortran
code out there
did it I didn't want to write fortune
all day but if I wrapped it one so that
you'd call Python it would use the
Fortran to do their work so I kind of
became really really good at rapping in
scientific code that was basically my
one skill set that then I had friends
fortunately who you know don't let
friends rapport track code manually and
one guy in particular really kind of
stepped up and helped me because you saw
that 1999 that was just one series of
posts after another I went back to the
mailing list archives and looked at it
and man I really do much work that year
did I tried to hide that from my family
like no I wasn't my PhD not just wasting
my time spending on all these tools but
I was so addicted I had so much fun it
was this before Facebook before
Instagram the way we shared ourselves is
we would write code and put up an
ugly-looking
web page and you look down the stuff and
yeah it was boring back then and it was
really fun people all over the world
would download it install it and send it
back information diff files not pull
requests they would use the patch
command and they would send it there's a
little bit more work and you'd send an
email with a diff you have to take that
diff and figure out if you could apply
it but that's how we did it and we made
progress so all of these packages came
out kind of one by one early on and
there was no packaging so packaging was
a matter of you know tarballs build
install and see you pray you know hope
it works
and then actually a guy named Robert
Kern who is still active in the sci-fi
community ended up making a bunch of
Windows installers for all this stuff I
was doing and man then people really
started to use my stuff so that's was
the first kind of awareness of oh
actually packaging matters if we make it
available Windows then you get users and
that led to a lot of extra work so I
used numeric but I actually gave this
talk it's just something easy slides in
Estonian not my friend PR who was in
Estonia and he was huge in making sci-fi
come together so with Erik Jones had
some libraries I had a bunch of
libraries that written and PR uu had F 2
pi fundamentally saw these things I was
manually doing and said you're never
gonna grap the world's Fortran one by
one by yourself so being a computer
scientist he went wrote a tool to do
that right all scenic 8 xkcd comic where
they passed
salt and the guys like hey pass the salt
hey I'm working on it I'm giving a
script to pass the salt great
I'm just want the salt I was actually
the guy that just passed the salt
multiple times I was a little more
pragmatic I suppose and I kind of
realized that I wasn't exactly it was
more of scientists in the computer
scientists because I just want to get
stuff done the PR it was great he wrote
this tool to wrap everything so we're
working together again I'm very excited
to have him working together again on
the next thing I'm doing with XMD so
that I read a lot of packages then
basically in 2001 number a started arise
and it was basically the it was a person
out there wrote some adult in the image
and the image had these cool morphology
binary dilation erosion open closing
image processing with those kind of
operators he wrote that tool but I
worked on memory and it didn't work on
numeric and I had sci-fi and it worked
on numeric arrays and so I was really
frustrated like I have to copy my data
for numeric number eight or to use this
tool they really felt ugly it's like you
know what kind of world is it where we
can't write operators and have them work
on containers on arrays that are already
I already have my data in this container
you have to move it over to some other
container or do this operation which
should by all rights be able to be
applied to the one I've got why can I do
that well cuz that's the way it was
working so I got I got I said well what
if I just wrote something that merged
these two you know I got some free time
I've got a month or two free time surely
I can do this in a month or two so
that's what I did in 2005 was that
basically at a class I was teaching
University and I said didn't nobody
showed up for it
it was a radio it was basically a
software radio class for building an MRI
and I only got one register and then
they dropped and so I sort of didn't
tell anybody had free time and so I said
well I'll just write this thing and so I
dug in I basically took the features of
memory and pour them to the code base of
numeric and spent about six months and
had a working version in another year or
making it actually really work with all
the bug reports that came in by that
those first brave souls he's trying it
out the first year and so that wasn't an
umpire working
2005-2006 and of course the key to any
open-source project is that it obtains a
community of users and developers as
well
contributors know open-source product
I'm aware of actually succeeds alone it
definitely requires a small group of
people to move it forward you know one
two three maybe five people to get it
started but it does not succeed unless
there's enough people who pay attention
and care about it to move it forward
again many contributors in that process
you can see over and over and over again
but there's still basically a power-law
you look at the number of contributors I
think there's about five to six people
who actually maintain numpy now there
were 600 on contributors or more now
there's a bunch of contributors but only
a few who actually are there and one of
them is not me anymore right so about
2012 I kind of backed away it's I really
don't have time so you don't expect
anything don't expect me be like I can
weigh in on occasion if you need
something but unfortunately there's some
really great people Charles Harris a
step tubs Stephan there's a bunch of
other folks who have jumped in and
Daniel who are maintaining write and
that's a lot of work to maintain and
it's uh it's very important work sigh
polymers and other things so Syfy I kind
of stepped away from the sidelines in
2009-2010 because that was started in
1999 right so these are my babies for
about ten years and then I had to
basically I got I I wasn't able to
provide for my family and work full-time
and open source right and so it's that's
basically been a personal thing I've
been really like how do you make this
work how can we actually make a world
where people can work on open-source and
still have a job
now it is starting I mean there's there
to be a lot of ways that happens and so
but not always for this group of people
you know numpy and sci-fi are still a
lot of people do it on their free time
they're kind of take it from their
employers a little bit employers aren't
really yeah you work on this half full
time so it's it's it's a real tell you
that story to kind of give you an
insight into why do i why do I think
about this I've been carrying and
thinking about sustainable open-source
since I was a young graduate student
with three kids making 18,000 a year
trying to figure out how am I gonna
provide for my family and still do this
thing that I love which is collaborate
on open-source
software with the world I'll gonna do it
and I'm still trying to figure that out
be honest experiment a lot that a lot of
different things over the course of
those 20 years and but I think we're
coming across things that actually work
and some ideas that work so there's a
preview I'll talk about this a little
bit later after I talk about kind of
what this has led me to today one of the
projects that we were working on a Quon
site and I've been kind of under an
anaconda previously we were working on
this really kind of with one person it
really not much of a funded effort but a
little bit of effort about three years
ago I had an idea and it actually was a
little earlier than that but you know
since we started in a condom and you
know I left I was working on numpy from
2006 to 2012 off and on trying to you
know help the community help things work
but of course over that time I saw it
used by millions of people knew
personally thousands of those people saw
the opportunities and challenges they
had with it and said things here aren't
there needs to be fixes so these things
when it gets you applied in scale
there's there's challenges so all kinds
of problems had a whole list of in 2012
and I get talks about these are the
fifties of problems how do we fix it but
didn't quite know what to do right
because how do you how do you fix it how
do you how do you take something that's
used by everybody and then tweak it to
make it better right it's really hard
turns out you know Microsoft they just I
mean everybody there's two answers right
you'll either iterate slowly and improve
things slowly or you build something new
right and I think you can point to
historical evidence of both of those I
tend to think in um PI's case that to
really get it to be where it needs to be
to for the Mater for the world ahead of
us to get the same capabilities but in a
different setting it has to be refactor
and has to be you know rewritten those
doesn't mean umpires gonna disappear
what I think is gonna happen not explain
kind of my thinking as to what I think
is gonna be gonna happen now I put numpy
2.0 here in quotes of parentheses
because I won't decide this one charge
deciding what happens if I'm high right
numpy
a community project it's governed by a
steering Council of people that have to
agree on what happens to umpire right so
I don't have an opinion I might raise it
I can voice a view about what we ought
to do and I can even put a prototype
together but numpy won't move unless all
those folks agree right it's gonna be
coming an animus decision the way I've
seen that work in the past is basically
people move when things work and so it's
it's a slow process
which is really good if you're if you're
relying on something it's sort of a way
to have maintenance and a way for things
to stay very very stable but it can be
very difficult to innovate in that in
that environment actually so but I think
that's okay I think that open source
provides the ability to kind of have
both strong things are stable as well as
opportunities to innovate in other ways
so I'll talk a little more about X and D
and kind of this project that we've been
working on that we're going to be coming
out with sort of PyCon will be the first
time we're talking about I just got a
website up X in the IO the project the
github has been going on for a couple of
years but we've had one person
committing quite a bit to it and then
we're starting a team around it there's
about three people now committing it
very regularly to the project and I'm
really excited about where it's going to
go and possibilities for what we can do
in the future with it so that's that's
that's one topic we'll get back to and I
want to talk more about are there any
questions on kind of the history of
numpy side pie anything else where I can
address there yes correct so number is
just number the only thing that is
really used here all these are new so
liability data data shape is older
Levantine addition many times GX of the
data fabric all those are new leonardo
random like those are all new the only
thing that is out there is number and
the point here is basically saying hey
we've got a compiler now we can rethink
how we do this we've got a JIT compiler
in Python no number lets us just write
Python code and get machine code
and like I've said multiple times if I'd
had that in 2000 back in 1998-99 when I
was writing sci-fi I don't written
things a lot differently I things were
been a lot different actually and so
it's a powerful tool that's available
now and no but just taking a little
while but it's not quite at one point no
it's trying to reach one point oh this
this year likely I don't know do you
have any updates been heard from them
I talked to Stan pretty regularly but
it's uh it's a powerful tool and what's
exciting is that Intel and NVIDIA and
other vendors have started to the vision
of it was to create a platform where
vendors could make it work for their
hardware and people are starting to
numbers starting to do that so I'm
really excited by that that was a number
was one of the projects we started when
we started a continuum and it's really
exciting to see it it kind of reached
its potential you know still more to do
but it's exciting to see that happen all
right sure yeah number who knows what
number is raise your hand he does thank
you great you know what number is oh my
goodness you're gonna be so happy if
you're a Python user how many know what
Python is raise your hand okay there's
biggest sure we'd have to go there so
number is a compiler for Python it takes
Python code and creates machine code out
of it so different than like a tracing
JIT it doesn't try to like sample your
code and decide for you when to compile
it it basically is you decorate code and
it converts code you decorate to machine
code so it's kind of a runtime ahead of
time compiler for numerical computing
primarily like it really doesn't help
you make your dictionary of lists of
dictionary objects faster like have you
got a if you're using Python and you
have very you know these these deeply
nested structures of dictionaries and
lists and you're using all that
indirection it's not going to make that
faster but if your data is stored in
columns its arrays and you're basically
doing array indexing on those big those
kind of data sets of typed data it can
make that code as fast as C it's as if
you wrote C code and you're writing
Python loops and so it's really
interesting because you can write very
simple code and have it very very fast I
have you know there's no I can give
examples of that actually if we have
time
it actually surprised like that's really
cool it's you know treat yourself to
some number I'd say right it's really
cool you know when you start to realize
oh my goodness that's possible you know
one of the reina Barba is a friend of
mine who teaches it you you George
Washington University and she has a
course she'd because it gives a talk but
he says tell your C++ bullies to go home
right cuz she gets some black people all
right the C++ because it's the only way
to get speed and she's gone oh look at
this I got Python code number fast as
your C++ code that's true so I thought
is a dip it's a there's use cases where
there overlap they can both be use
together but they tend have different
use cases a scythe on is typically used
to build an extension module ahead of
time where you specifically give it
types so scythe on you give it types I
think I don't I actually I don't but I
can quickly get it I think if it bends
is still if Ben's stuff is still working
for me so cond install numba I don't I
don't have interconnect I this has been
dropping I'm now on a different network
that's been having this trouble keeps
dropping my network how many people are
Conda users here okay that's better
good good you'll all have an easier time
installing number nodes you can tip and
stone them but now but it's it's really
like I tell when your hip installing are
complex
see dependency you're just sort of
giving yourself technical debt to
unravel later right it may work and it
worked fine for a little while but
unless you really structured it well and
maybe inside of the docker container and
your architecture too well the Internet
is really full of information that's
cause you technical problems later it's
unfortunate really but it's what's
happening it's kind of a consequence of
one mm the big benefit of pythons it
brings all us together the web
programmers the system Adam is is the
jaw the kind of computer science
programmers with scientists and array
people that would use MATLAB otherwise a
Fortran we all come together to Python
that we think a little bit differently
when you go to Python it's very clear
Jake Vander Plaats gave a great talk
about the different diversity of pipe
icon you may meet people you don't
understand
unfortunately the packaging community in
Python has been a little bit one-sided
and they've kind of you know Nick
Coughlin has been very very good at
communicating about how this you know
the purpose of PIP and where it fits and
how kind of plays a role but there's
been others very very super excited
about kind of thinking that tip is going
to be how you package the world and it's
not it's not it can't work that way so
people get into trouble when they pip
install only so Kannada is a it's more
like young and brew and apt-get so if
you think of Connor you think of
actually instead of using brew or
instead of using applicant how many
years Conda and then I can use pip as
well on top I need to but that's the way
you got to think about a comment hip our
competitors Conda and brewer competitors
right that's the that's the right way to
think about it to install numba it
depends on something called l vm l vm is
a compiler tool chain that is used in
claim which the C++ compiler so you
effectively have a compiler right knows
nothing about Python oh yeah I mean
there's nothing about Python so you have
to install that somehow right in order
to run numb but you got to have LLVM
Conda can install of yeah I'm just just
fine then it installs a wrapper color'
of lamb light and then with that you
have the makings of a tool that lets you
compile Python code so now they're
having installed let's go to my duper
lab session and this is really small
probably write better
oh it's back there okay yeah cool
very good so basically you just have
this very simple ability to write a
function and I'll do two kinds of
functions I'll do a function that just
basically returns X let's do if okay
thank you it's not better how's that
right so there you go there's your
little function right so this function
is meant to take two integers and then
just basically the absolute value
effectively return the difference
depending on which is greater so I can
from numba there's a little thing called
vectorize and this is what I always
wanted when I was writing on PI I wanted
something that would take Python code
and give me what's called the universal
function or a map that would work over
all elements of an array and use the
same broadcasting rules that ad and sy
and every function all these functions
in numpy do and none but gave it to me
we donated a bunch to get it but I have
you know we have we basically went and
wrote a tool that would take Python
syntax convert it to LLVM and compiled
to machine code just like sealing clang
take C++ syntax compiles a Delvian makes
machine code out of it it really makes
Python on par with C++ now there's some
deed there's some nuances there because
okay wait a minute
well there's no types here so how do you
that manage that well you actually don't
actually create machine code until you
call this with something so I have to
first you know make an array of let's
just go one to a hundred
why why equals let's do x1 backwards
right so it kind of gives me the
negative absolute value right the way
I've done that so that'd be fun
now what if I just called func on x1 and
y1 I think that's gonna do to give me
air it's gonna say wait X less than Y
X's an array and Y how do i I don't know
what to do I know what to do you know
what this means X less than Y it doesn't
work it it needs so what'd be fun does
it translates a scalar function to a
vectorized as to a to a function that
will work across the array but it
compiles it to a gene code so this is
fast and it's as fast as you can make
functions very very fast that map across
your array very quickly very easily that
gets really neat when you start talking
about generalizing funks which are
kernels that work on a rake rate chunks
so using vector eyes you can think about
your data as arrays that the chunks of
data and little kernel operators that
work on chunks of those data when you
think about your data that way
turns out you think about the data the
same way the computer wants to think
about the data and therefore you can
write very fast code one of the problems
we have today is that a lot of computer
science teaching has taught people to
think about their data differently than
the way the computer thinks about it
they're taught them to think about in
terms of objects scattered all over
memory and then the computer or compiler
world has to work really really hard
even maybe even do something with that
make it fast and doesn't always succeed
doctor rarely succeeds that especially
becomes problematic we are talking about
GPUs with numba we can take this
function and actually target the GPU or
target parallel and we can run in
parallel run on GPU so with number but
at your side you basically you know
people tell you hello python it's got
the Gil it's not parallelizable
what are you talking about number of
target parallel I'm using multiple ten
course but you have a tool here very
simple code very simple modification if
you're using numpy arrays or or array
come array constructs the same time so
numbers a powerful tool that was it was
the idea came from initially and it's
been making rapid progress with targets
GPUs it's the easiest way to program GPU
I know about so that's that's that's the
easiest part then you can just do
general things like you can just JIT
code to so the purpose of JIT would if I
had a loopy function and I had an array
like this I could do a for loop for I in
range a length of a like this and just
do something like a I
let's do result equals empty empty okay
and then I gotta return something okay
so then you get this is simple for not a
problem if my loop is like a hundred
elements so I can do that but when I was
with a million you know what happens
about two for loops inside of each other
are four for loops if you're doing a
convolution over two-dimensional array
you never do that in Python right well
if I can vectorize if I can get that and
compile it to machine code sure no
problem
and that's what you have number also has
a JIT so number jet you've had in loopy
so these uses decorators or over
functions and give you new functions you
know fast would be right and now that is
working over the entire array but now
it's the machine code right so you
basically can and if there's some work
it has to do there because if you look
at this this code this is a template
there's no type information bacteria's
little question about scythe on scythe
on is similar except you have to tell
the types you have to say oh this loop
this I variable is an int this a is a
array of type so it gets really bulky
numba in first types for you it
understands oh I called this with a
array of type float or so I can I know
that this must be a float type I have a
loop index that must be an integer it
infers those types and generates machine
code accordingly so it's some type
inference automatic kind of construction
machine code powerful it's a powerful
tool it was actually took about two and
a half years to write something was
actually pretty usable maybe three years
yeah after three years it's kind of
usable I know Ben keep me honest was the
idea was pretty exciting for a long time
but if you haven't used number numbers
up there actually the heart of a lot of
the things you see coming out of
anaconda like data shader the in
tertiary is number of the covers you
look at desk desk desk is a paralyzation
library I won't go into that but
definitely should look up desk makes you
understand what it is desk is pythonic
spark right so desk is kind of what
happen and people look to spark and said
how should you really do this in Python
you know I've said to people PI spark is
a gateway drug to scholar it is right I
mean cuz you basically are struggling
with PI spark and freezing I'll just go
to Scala they like I hate myself why did
I go this go ahead right but it kind of
does take you down that path gask is
kinda like well if I'm actually using
Python what would it look like
oh look like this and you're sort of now
it's lights turn on you feel like it's
pythonic it's all--it's you're happy you
know until your administrator may be
giving you a grief about charting gas
workers fortunately that's getting
easier and easier but it's really a
powerful tool you combined dot skin
number naive actually you really were
able to solve kind of one of the
fundamental problems we really were we
started continuing to do is just scale
out Python to ask a number give us a
scale up scale out solution that really
you can take Python and go go a long
long ways so pretty exciting actually
definitely one things I'm happy about
you can yeah all the decorator does is a
syntax syntactic sugar for that
operation
yeah it kind of depends on what you're
trying to accomplish
so JIT is the most general like jet you
can write any for loop or anything and
because structure how you like vectorize
is okay I'm gonna write a kernel over an
array and it kind of that's less general
but sometimes easier to think about
secondly the code writes that outer loop
for you and it does it in a way that's
consistent with how numpy writes loops
and really when it combines loops like
the power is you get the same kind of
object that python itself uses or numpy
use this to do addition and subtraction
the broadcasting basically if I have
arrays that aren't the same shape it
gives you the same capability so it
makes a way to make you thunks no well
yes vector eyes will be a little faster
sometimes
on smartphones not present not that I
know of I mean theoretically but yeah
you'd have to basically I don't I don't
know if it's heart we haven't targeted I
haven't seen it targeted to smartphone
platform you have Python there you'd
have to have I guess you could cross
compile potentially with lbm you could
potentially think about cross compiling
you know producing machine code that
would work on a phone that would be
possible but it certainly isn't out of
the box something that is easy right it
would take some elbow grease to make
that happen but you could you could get
a handle of the code that's generated
from the Python code the number
producers are bringing LLVM and it's
retarget smartphone code absolutely
could do that you just have to dig in
and probably use LVM light the inner
line tool underneath the covers yeah
good question yeah not to get to in the
weeds but I've seen this before
and see where it becomes a template
problem the house you don't know the
detour dealing with and so you dispatch
based on type and you end up having a
different version of Looby based on each
yes I you correct that's exactly what
happens here okay this exactly what you
end up having an N squared problem if
you are trying to add two arrays and you
don't know the types of either one um so
it basically constructs a version for
the if you pass in a float and and it'll
construct a version for floating int
maybe you could put an int float
it'll construct another version for an
float and you know it basically does
exactly what you asked for
so yeah you could have like all of them
but in practice you don't because you
build what you need for your use case Oh
cuz it's JIT it's just after the yes it
can she knows the types correct so the
big difference is numpy had to
pre-compute ahead of time all these
loops right this just computes them on
the fly and then caches it and stores it
so you can actually have a note you
could have an umpire that uses this
number that was a lot less there's a lot
smaller didn't have those pre-compile
loops because it would just compile them
and cache them
you need to so it's a lot more you know
a lot simpler right there's a lot of
problems that it solves that are I'm
kind of excited by presently I'm
thinking a lot about the web as a
platform your web assembly is emerging
and you could you think about you know
compiling them using number to compile
to web assembly and have an in client in
in browser executables I think it's
fairly possible over the next two or
three years we'll see a lot of in
browser clients sorry in browser
runtimes it's different I'm different
experience a little bit like the phone
conversation browser is probably closer
to the phone I mean you might see in the
browser then the browser is how it gets
to the phone because you have a web
assembly on the phones and somebody
takes care of that computation so you
wouldn't need to necessarily I mean
typically you the C++ producers machine
code and python steers that machine code
right Python is very good at gluing that
with the rest of it and then having that
kind of combined system where it's all
working together that's usually the way
it works in those those cases all right
let's see if we can move on a little bit
sorry but that was fun actually no but I
love number number was the thing where
things are so excited about we spent a
lot of time on it and I don't get to
spend as much time with those folks
anymore that was one of the downsides of
starting something new but I mean they
could do some other things too so that's
always fun I want to give you a little a
little window into what I'm doing now
just because like I said the the problem
of sustainable of a source is a personal
some I really care about in fact one of
the you know Anaconda continuum anaconda
we were very successful at creating a
lab kind of an Innovation Lab that had
you know at any one time about 30 people
who were working on open source software
some of which was pretty directly tied
to anaconda enterprise or anaconda
product story and some which was not
really directly tied it was more broader
it kind of
sort of partly because the product story
emerged after the fact you know we had a
big broad mission in the products for
emerge that was smaller and more narrow
but I loved the fact that we had the
sustainable story we had this
sustainable lab that we built and it was
doing a lot of great things and super
excited about that
so basically when anaconda sort of
focused its energy around the enterprise
software story that it has the board and
I agreed that I would spin off another
company it would basically continue the
broader mission of supporting open
source doing general purpose consulting
to do that and that's one side and
effectively the way I see the way look
at this it's continuum give rice
anaconda and if we structured it right
to begin with we would have spy out on a
kind of separate company but it's kind
of an hindsight hard to do that once you
get bunch of investors around the table
and a bunch of you know stakeholders you
have to kind of it's some things you
can't unravel that it's that simply so
we start this one quonset we've
organized like that it's racing
incubation services company that
sustains open source has it's a lab has
helped people fund open source and then
we look for product ideas as we find
them we'll spin out new companies right
so you go to our website Quonset comm
and there's a story for multiple people
there's story for community members a
story for developers who want to work
with us there's a story for
entrepreneurs who want to come and help
spin-out companies using our model and
then there's a story for what what are
we selling today what are we doing today
we basically do three things a company
we grow talent we discover it we build
technology and we discover products we
grow talent by working with people and
recognizing that it's not a university
degree it's not twelve weeks a bootcamp
that make you a data scientist it's on
the job working with people that know
what they're doing and that
apprenticeship model we just embracing
that if you're internal medicine the
guide stuff of teaching hospital
you got to where doctors are really made
they're not made in medical school or
made in the teaching hospitals and we're
basically building a teaching hospital
for data scientists or teaching
environment so we've met our data
scientist and get them paired up we have
a quat we have a quad sight labs and OSS
dev team we work on whatever like a lot
of projects really that will depend on
the people to join us and what they're
interested in you're looking a continuum
when it got into the end there's a few
things we started with but it kind of
grew
some of people that joined and what they
were passionate about what they wanted
to grow then we do general services to
fund this we work for people and we to
work that they need done that's a big
deal
we've just introduced this model we're
just it's kind of something we have seen
it h2o I've seen it at continuum I said
anaconda I saw it at typesafe and other
companies
it's basically recognising the need for
a transmission for a quarter wave
transformer for a group that connects
companies to open source communities
there's a lot that can be done there so
we encapsulate that what we call the
sustainable open-source subscription we
go to companies help them understand how
they can get the things they need out of
open source they can find people to hire
who are around these open source
projects and then they can mitigate
their risk associate with open source
one another a set of other features
those the three principal ones and
that's what we do for companies that's
what they pay for for communities we
help them organize their roadmap and
organize their what they want to
accomplish and present it in a way that
can be funded and so we kind of have we
were a market and connect the open
source communities with with companies
super excited by it we're having some
success already we're just barely
starting this few weeks but very excited
about this that's kind of work we're
after what we're doing at anaconda you
know my next iteration I'm figuring out
how to help sustainable open source is
this model so if you work someplace you
think you're using open source think
your company might be interested in in
helping this effort give me a call let
me know and we'll have a global talk
yeah yeah so some of this is funding
open source authority exists right so I
would actually expect there'd be a 10 to
1
you know we'd support 10 projects and
then one might be new right that's maybe
it's five to one that would I would
expect it's to sustain other other
products that are there help
organizations use those as well as start
new ones that are help organize data
according to the way people believe it
might might happen so that's kind of
them that's kind of model
absolutely yeah absolutely yeah our
default is to make a copy package right
and make it available accessible in the
Anaconda ecosystem yeah absolutely
now you know obviously anaconda will be
it will we'll manage that themselves all
right so this is an example of the kind
of you know we make brochures we talk to
the communities organize their roadmaps
and maybe we're just starting this
process of effectively running marketing
and sales playbooks around open source
roadmaps so super excited by that that's
what we're doing and it kind of adds on
to the work we did when I started
continuing became anaconda Nunn focus we
also started um focus which continues to
go and it's basically an or it's an
organization that's fiscally sponsors
these organization helps them helps them
maintain their community spirit it's
really important that at one site we
honor the communities as they exist and
we help them be heals communities you
know we don't come in and say here's
we're going to take over your governance
we're gonna take over how you do this no
in fact we're gonna help you understand
how do you do this how the communities
want to do it and maybe facilitate
conversations between people that maybe
things get stalled because it's the
conversations aren't happening people
are just not talking to each other I
mean we sort of help that process along
kind of using the experience we have in
doing that so that's so we think about
the projects we're interested in I will
finish by telling you and that's
probably right I don't have enough
material to go into more depth talk
about xnd like I said numpy we found out
one of the principal problems of numpy
was the type system could not be
extended very easily it it was it's also
very very tied to the Python C API so
everybody who wanted to use pi PI or
JSON or ironpython
is really hard to get access to the rain
computing because they had to
reimplemented on C API and they didn't
do that it became a stumbling block for
every one of those other altered
alternative views of Python to work so
the idea of xnd is basically say look
we're not going to rewrite numpy we're
going to take
the concepts of numpy breaking apart
into independent libraries see libraries
that can then have in the sea libraries
that are cross language so our and Julia
a node and other and webassembly other
things can use those libraries to
implement basic concepts and then have
Python interfaces of the principal ones
that are libraries that can be used by
anybody to an array computer in python
including a numpy 2.0 perhaps and so in
the future but most particularly in the
meantime it's things like task arrays
and x-ray and pandas potentially there's
a lot of people out there using numpy
under the covers who could be using
libraries instead there's a lot of a lot
of learning we did one of the principles
of learning was an umpire acts as a user
library sent as a user interface
sometimes like a thing you as the data
science will use interact with initially
that was its intent as the years have
passed on it's actually more like a
library now but how you write a library
and python is very different than how
you write that final application layer
and so there's some things in numpy that
that kind of smell weird because they're
you know as if you use a library you're
like wait why are you doing that just
just raise an error or give me back some
as quickly so I'm just kind of learning
like that that we're applying but the
big thing is the type system so we start
with nd types and nd types is basically
just a simple way to it was how who's
heard of arrow here like what's exciting
to me is that you know Wes and I are
saying the same thing about different
things he's basically saying the same
thing about pandas that I'm saying about
numpy which is basically we need to
write we need to write about containers
that are common across languages rather
than having Python as the data frame and
Python has an X and numpy array and then
julia has one and then r has one no we
have a common way to talk about
container data and it interfaces to
different languages so that we can we
don't have to copy data around just to
simply do computation with another
language so comparing so which arrow and
x and e yeah so how would you compare
and contrast numpy and pandas yeah so
you know numpy is X India's pandas as
the arrow is we had sachet that's the
simplest way to understand it
Exedy tends to be more my hypothesis is
that we can describe a narrow container
with x and DS type system so that the
arrow container is a kind of shared
container X and E can basically
represent many many kinds of containers
for all kinds of data structures and
then there's the question will be will
there be computation systems built on
those type systems I'm not sure
right because are you gonna at the FD
ndnd types is much more general any x
can describe you know pointers to data
structures of all kinds they can
describe linked lists it can describe
you know but pretty much it's antennae
described blocks of data now geo math is
about it's of X and D is then basically
a pointer to a memory block and a
description of that memory block with
NDT with any types just like an umpire
it has a D type it describes it how many
folks are familiar with num PI's D types
so I have an example here because it's
just a very simple example but kind of
illustrates you know before pan is
existed people kind of were enticed by
these structure arrays in numpy we had
this ability to find an array of
structures I could have a type that
itself was tends to a string of 10 and
integer and a float and if I have an
array of those it kind of looks like a
data frame it's a little different
though because it's all one contiguous
blocks an array of structures the
difference with the data frame is you
usually want it flipped you want to
transpose of that you want a structure
of arrays you want the integers all
together you want the floats all
together and you want the strings all
together this structured data type that
numpy provides gives you records all
together right you have strain float and
then you have another one it's more row
based and so it's not always what you
want but it does it does get a very
compact way to describe data and you can
basically point to that data and with an
X and D by adding a reference data type
by having a pointer data type we can now
basically construct a array a structure
of arrays as well because you know we
got on a pointer to an integer array of
10 we got a pointer to an integer array
a float array and you can basically
scribe a pen
data frame now do you have a computation
system on top of that well if you write
one if you if you register functions
that work with that then yes that's what
geo math provides this is a mechanism to
create registrations of functions that
work on those type systems
yeah they don't worry not this or does
really cool act it's the one part of
blaze that hasn't been yet salvaged in
something else right like it's kind of
orphaned right now it needs help it's
hopeful it's one I hope to be able to
kind of reconnect to something that's
more maintainable because it needs to be
refactored in order to be to continue
but yeah oh noes a cool tool right uses
some of these ideas but not really it's
kind of separate odo is more this is
more about description of the data type
odo is more about high-level semantics
of you know interfaces to serialization
code so it's getting to the weeds I
realize there's a lot of detail here but
at the end of the day X and D gives you
at a high level the ability to have
arbitrary containers of arbitrarily type
data and then a function system that
lets you define kernels and find
functions that work on that we'll use
number in order to generate those
kernels so very quickly we can basically
build operations on any kind of data
strains pointers of strings arrays of
whatever you like it's all accessible so
the infrastructure is there GM out and
this gene math is very new and the
attacks have been working on for about
three years
XMD came out basically in December
January GM math is just like the last
few weeks so this is very very new and
there's lots of work to be done don't
expect to see this in your bag of tools
for at least a year I'd say right if
you're like a user anyone gonna be able
to play with this yeah a year maybe if
you're a developer I want to play with
it you can do that today if you want to
use it as a way to kind of play around
and see what you can do but so that's X
indeed that's what I'm working on now a
little bit history of where I've been
and what I'm doing now love to take
questions and kind of talked about what
you'd like me to say for the rest of the
time
for a few questions you know I've looked
into that I don't think so no I don't
think so no unfortunately yeah I know in
that horrible yeah that's barely very
even useful of a response but I will
point you out to something be one of the
first people to look at something we're
rolling out at PyCon we're announcing so
in this process of doing open source
development bringing to companies
opportunities to fund open source we're
going to need a lot of people who want
to either be freelancers or work for us
full time to work on open source and so
the way we're doing this work we have a
we have a website open team quan site
comm there's basically a and if I can
get the Wi-Fi anywhere been shut me off
now anyway go there it's very very
minimal it's basically a way to register
hey I'm interested here's what I kind of
need to make and it's all private gbg
PDR compliant we will you know erase it
if you want us to but it gives us an
idea of who's available where they need
to be working its kind of building a
database of ok I'm available to work on
open source so this is me and if you go
there is you you'll be able to log in
and decide and tell us what you're
working where you can work what you need
to be paid and basically raise your hand
and say I'm available
so go ahead and done that's it that's
what I've got
so what I know each other really really
well
we talk a lot right I would say we've
interacted right now we're kind of
pursuing like low-level details that
aren't exact
the same thing on the same things we're
very aware of the projects and so and we
may want to collaborate where it makes
sense right I'm super excited to
potentially help like what I hope do at
one site is fund a bunch of labs
you know Quonset labs will probably only
ever be twenty thirty people my wildest
dreams to be a hundred people are they
awesome
but I think the opportunity is there for
thousands of people ten thousand people
and I'd like to fund other labs so I
would love to partner with ursa labs oh
sure yeah people benchmark these all the
time it's you know benchmarks are it's
challenging you have to determine
whether it's useful for you but there's
there's frameworks haven't I meant
profile frameworks not really an API per
se there's there's frameworks for
running benchmarks tree structures now
xnd does can define a tree structure and
you can confined that you can define a
function that works over that it's
actually pretty sophisticated now it's
it's not trivial but you can do even to
find a ragged array in xnd you're going
to find a ragged array of rough rough
pointers as long as you write a function
that kind of that can deal with that you
can do it and you can register that
again will people do it we'll see right
how complicated i want to be of course
ya know duper came out not up didn't
come out of any kind of lab the duper
lab did come out of anaconda lab act
activity in conjunction with the jupiter
team like these are all cooperative
efforts they're these are very
cooperative efforts it's one thing I
love about the open-source community is
we you know we we don't you don't always
get a hundred people row in the same
direction exactly but at least you're
aware of each other and you're trying to
float a proximally in the right row in
the same direction cool so let's wrap it
up there I'd like to thank Travis for
there's pizza on the counter over there
and I know what I'm gonna be doing on my
spare time which is learning how to give
in the circumstances still give a
fantastic clock and also live coding
what you don't see is that I used to be
a lot better 10 years of running
companies instead of writing code all
day